welcome back to uncensor Israel is
divided over its hostage deal with Hamas
which has now been extended for further
two days one major poll found that 45%
of Israeli Jews oppos the ongoing
prisoner swap while just 40% support it
idar BV a right-wing security minister
called it a very very big mistake so
does negotiating with terrorists weaken
Israel's position or should Israel's
allies be pressing to make this
ceasefire permanent my next guests have
clashed in the past on Miss show with
the crisis in Gaza last time they appear
together I they keep the dialogue open
is the only way forward and they' both
be invited back and so tonight they're
invited back and I'm joined by nering
kiswani the activist and founder of the
Palestinian Community organization
within our lifetime and by the
journalist and broadcaster Emily Austin
welcome to both of you Nadine let me
start with you if I may uh there's a a
pause at the moment it's been extended
by two more days there are hostages
being released back to Israel there are
prisoners being released back to uh the
Palestinians what is your view of where
things should move from
here I think it's important that when we
talk about hostages who also understand
that there are thousands of Palestinian
prisoners that have been held in Zionist
Dungeons and Zionist prisons uh for
years and years and um it's important
that they are also freed and that the
2.3 million Palestinians in Gazza uh
which is effectively a concentration
camp are also being held hostage so I
think all hostages um should be be freed
when we look at the context of
Palestinians prisoners um and not to
call them hostages but understanding
that it's you know the same uh kind of
line of thinking all right Emily Austin
I mean the thing about the Palestinian
prisoners you've been in Israeli jails I
was shocked by not necessarily the age
of so many of them because I knew a lot
of young teenagers in particular had
been rounded up for throwing rocks at
soldiers and so on but the fact that so
many are being held in detention without
charge
that makes me feel very uncomfortable
are you comfortable with
that um most of the prisoners that were
part of this exchange were actually
tried and you know convicted of the
crimes most of them being attempted
murder there is a narrative going around
that there hasn't been Fair trials that
they haven't been convicted but that's
simply not true and there's one in
particular that's going very very viral
on Twitter of Ahmed al- man al- manra
who was convicted at 12 years old old
this is a photo of him then a photo of
him now and they're saying that he was
abused in Israeli prisons but if you
look closely you could see him stabbing
two civilians at 14 years old and a lot
of them are calling this kid innocent
just because he's a child but at 14
years old if you're stabbing civilians
you might be a child but you're
definitely not innocent and contrary to
what nerine just said there is no
equivalency this is not a hostage
exchange this is an exchange of
criminals for children okay these are
babies who are being held captive for
someone who tried to stab a soldier
another baby for another woman who tried
to stab a soldier another baby whose
crime was being a Jew versus another
woman who tried to stab another Soldier
vers another baby whose crime is being
an Israeli who was released for a woman
who tried to stab a soldier so I'm sorry
this is not a hostage exchange this is a
criminal exchange for our civilians back
who are taken out of their homes okay
Nadine respond to that thousands of yeah
thousands of Palestinians are held under
administrative detention which as you
said means that they don't even get
charged with anything let alone a fair
trial and that these administrative
detention um you know detentions can be
renewed every six months and even when
Palestinians are tried often times
Palestinians are tried in military
courts and there's a 99% or higher than
99% conviction rate of Palestinians
being tried in military courts children
are not tried in military courts
anywhere else around the world um on top
of that Palestinians get 20 years just
for throwing stones let let me ask you
about this question of a permanent
ceasefire Israel just made it clear to
me through their government spokesman
they got absolutely no intention of
having any ceasefire this war continues
in their eyes until they have defeated
Hamas what is your response to
that is the murder of 20,000
Palestinians 8,000 of them being
children not enough you know I think
that no matter what they say um no
matter who they're going after there's
always going to be Palestinian
resistance so that argument um is
essentially saying that they're never
going to stop killing Palestinians and
that they're completely justified in
doing so would
you let me would you categorize what
happened on October the 7th as
resistance sorry I didn't hear your
would you categorize what happened on
October the 7th as
resistance I yeah I would categorize it
um as resistance and it's my
categorization where that's coming from
terrorism is there any categorization of
Palestinian resistance armed resistance
that you wouldn't categorize as ter
several thousand would I think when
several thousand people sto over a
border hang on let me let me just
respond I think when several thousand
people storm over a border and attack
peaceloving people in a in kutes and
butcher them to death raking people's
heads off killing babies
were killed by Israel itself Israel
actually that Israel incinerated a
12-year-old we have to agree though
before we get to before we get to
Israel's response you must accept that
what happened that day was an act of
terrorism
surely I don't live in a concentration
camp and neither do you and neither does
Emily I haven't lived under the brutal
conditions that the people of Gazza have
had to endure for the better part of the
last two decades it's not up to me to
tell people who are breaking free from a
concentration camp how exactly they
should do that and like I said when
Palestinians Tred to do that this is the
Concentration Camp referring to this is
Gaza this is a very beautiful
concentration camp that is Gaza and it's
a damn shame that Hamas terrorists are
invading this very beautiful looking
concentration camp if only the Jews were
that lucky to have such a beautiful
concentration camp nardine listen Pierce
let's cut to the chase iot of
stop asking her to condemn October 7th
when she is borderline a terrorist
herself she herself incites violence she
herself protests and always incites
violence and vandalism even though
Vandal vandalism is not protected by our
first amendment so how do you expect her
to condemn terrorism when she has openly
said that it is an act of resistance and
she continues to justify it you're the
one defending m000 palan speaking I was
about
D and I don't care about you either and
I'm here to say I'm just going to keep
speaking
you're every single life that is taken
on either side is abhorent it is
atrocious and I wish you would stop
Israel cannot stop until Hamas is
defeated Israel is the only military in
the world that will knock on doors send
out pamphlets send out alarms on roofs
and warn civilians to leave and Hamas
will rather be
em psychological
Wares without their mothers and their
let ask question Emily Emily here's my
question for you is that I think there's
a real danger for Israel of this
happening sooner rather than later that
if they start attacking M South as well
as seems to be the intention after this
pause is over and the death toll of
innocent Palestinians continues to
Skyrocket and they can't produce any
hard evidence as they clearly can't at
the moment from my last interview uh of
how many actual Hamas terrorists they're
killing in the process that they're
going to lose the moral support and The
High Ground uh and the the global
support for them will disintegrate for
the for Israel that is a real a real
potential danger here I completely
disagree I think it's not is Israel did
its due diligence Israel did its part
they warned civilians to leave so all of
the condemning that Israel is receiving
Kash should be receiving because they
are using their civilian their their own
civilians their women and their children
as human Shields instead of having them
evacuate those who evacuated we can the
about
oer
should each refuges that should be don't
talk over each other let me go to Nadine
for
response we can say the same about
October 7th October 7th wouldn't have
happened if Israel was not occupying
Palestinian land if there wasn't a SI
and blockade on on Gaza if our land
wasn't stolen from us and this has been
clear here for so many years
Palestinians were talking about this
were protesting about this for years and
years and years while the world ignored
them why why are there kibes next to
gazza's border are they a buffer zone
are they human Shields actually it's
Israel that's using Judaism and using
its own citizens as human shield Shields
to Mass Slaughter to mass genocide
Palestinians can use all the different
term terrorists but it is Israel that
has killed Palestinian children not the
other way around do you believe hamash
should stay in power in Gaza hang hang
on Emily should should Nadin Hamas stay
in power in
Gaza I believe that Palestinians should
be free that's what I'm here I'm here
I'm here to say that won't answer your
question that's not up to me I don't
live I don't live in you got a very you
a lot of opinions about this is your
opinion that Hamas should stay in power
yes or
no I believe that Palestinians wouldn't
need resistance groups if you're not
going to answer the question all right
so no no that is answering the question
actually question given you several CH
no it is answering the question of
course they to stay in power or they
don't there wouldn't be a resistance
group such as Hamas or itself in power
if there wasn't anything to resist if
there wasn't an Israeli occation last em
Pi can I respond please I want to debunk
this occupation myth once and for all
nine when was the last time Palestinian
had full sovereignty over the land of
Israel when was the last date that they
had sovereignty over the land when was
the last prime minister when did you
have your
own
CLE C aan blockade I'm not here to
answer your question you're a genocide
den you're justifying on live television
the live Mur the
murder when did Palestine have
sovereignty over the land since she
can't answer it from me that's a
question she just called me a gen off of
our land your this is this is
Palestinian population
for generations and
generations you know sad thing you know
a
genocide OCC the sad thing about this is
at some point we are going to have to
bring the two sides together to reach a
peace settlement and yet every time I
bring people from both sides of this
debate together this is how it goes it
looks completely imp she's using land as
an excuse to kill let me speak to you
one I don't know why bring Sports
journalist who's obsessed who's obs with
making
terrorist sure call me a terrorist on
live television but it was three
Palestinian Americans who
were this is I want to say this I want
to say one
thing Americans were shot here on us
soil for wearing a scar so when you're
calling me a terrorist on TV and say
that there's incitement against you
you're actually
inciting
Muresan
em I'll leave you to both continue
shouting at each other I'm sorry it
ended like that I want to have
constructive debate this doesn't get
anyone anywhere but I appreciate you
both joining me again thank you on TV
un